today's episode of acting 101 is
sponsored by facto this podcast and
every other podcast that I produce is
also supported by patreon where they get
completely ad-free versions unedited
versions which includes an extra little
conversation at the start of this
specific episode extra content and early
content hello everyone welcome to
another episode of voice searching 101
I'm here with Nick Nick who are you and
what are you doing in my house
[__] I'm caught red-handed yeah I I'm
the Oreo delivery guy what do you mean
what am I doing here it's not lying he
did bring arios uh we just played
through some Resident Evil 4. on Twitch
this will publish days after that but
why did we do that
yes why did we do that um no I'm uh my
name is Nick pastelitis and I'm uh I'm
an actor in Los Angeles and I'm a big
ass gamer and that's why I'm here to
share some passion about video games and
talk about what what are we talking
about uh we're gonna talk about your
whole career um all of it from when you
were a wee lad
um but most recently in the voice of
Leon S Kennedy and
physical what's the correct phrasing for
body performance capture we'll call it
okay so the performance capture and
voice if we don't ask Kennedy in residue
before and Resident Evil 2 oh which is
what we were just playing obviously yes
so uh there's motion capture where you
capture the body but if you do uh full
performance capture in a game they you
have the head cam on yes people who
might have seen that um you got a camera
staring at your face you get sometimes
the dots they're recording your voice
your facial expression and your body at
the same time so it's really just like a
digital Avatar of you
it's kind of creepy but also very cool
but you can be anything and that's
what's cool about mocap is that you can
you can be a human you can be an ogre
you can be a creature a witch anything
and you get to see it in real time a lot
of time too right like you could see it
in real time cool it's it's such a cool
facet of video games but yeah to to walk
us back a little bit um how did you get
started
um how did I get started
everyone's always got an interesting
answer but they always say they don't
okay all right here here's here's my
answer
I I was working in Hospitality okay I
was my young 20s working in hotels and I
was around people all the time I was a
private level concierge and have you
ever heard the phrase that uh or the
saying that if if three random people
tell you something in your life that's
the Universe telling you that you should
do something you've never heard that
that's interesting okay so I'm working
at this hotel people all the time and I
heard about 50 times people asked me if
I was an actor or they said you should
try acting and they would keep saying
this and I would get really curious like
why and I would ask why and they said
because you have very honest eyes when
you speak wow and I was a concierge and
uh the role of a concierge can be taken
as very
smoogie like schmoozy because you're
going for the tip you always want the
tip and everything and I was just very
genuine I wanted to help people all the
time and when I kept hearing that I said
damn it maybe I should just try and so I
started to audition for student films in
Boston what I'm sorry what were your
aspirations at that time like did you
have a plan to be honest with you I I
didn't really know
um people urged me I worked in Disney
World back in the day my guest service
manager said you should be in
Hospitality you're good with people and
so I was like hey maybe I'm a
Hospitality guy I don't know and I got
into hotels and that was that's what led
me there and when I was auditioning for
these student films
I mean growing up I you know I was I was
just a regular guy I just you know
emulated characters like John McLean and
like Indiana Jones and like I of course
the little part of me was like I would
love to be an action hero one day and
then I started to book some roles in
student films in Boston and then you
know a couple years later I moved to LA
and here I am it is time to talk about
facta which is a meal service that I've
been using every single week for the
last several months actually people ask
me all the time how I manage my time
like how do I have a full-time job on a
YouTube channel and how did I do boxing
training as well and I promise you no
small part of that was because of facta
which is a meal delivery service that
delivers you healthy food high protein
options low calorie options keto options
directly to your doorstep every single
week basically every week you can select
which meals you want from fact is chefs
and all meals arrive prepared and ready
to eat in two minutes or less it's
actually even faster than ordering it in
fact it absolutely cuts out stressful
meal planning and extensive prepping so
meals come together in just a matter of
minutes it totally takes the guesswork
out of what you want to make each day
and they rotate in and out different
recipes so that it always feels fresh I
already mentioned they have keto and
calories and protein options but they do
also have vegan and vegetarian and more
than 27 meal options each week so that
is something for everyone meal plans
range from 4 to 18 meals per week and
you can add more or reduce the number
depending on your specific needs plus
you can easily modify food preferences
and skip a week if needed there are 33
extra options including smoothies keto
shakes desserts I will also say they
have some of the best customer service
that I've ever had from any service in
my life the people doing the customer
service don't know that factor sponsors
my YouTube channel so I'm just saying
that it's like a personal vouch so use
my link or go to
go.factor75.com and use code POG Alana
May 40 for 40 off plus 20 off your next
month huge thank you to facta for
sponsoring today's video and also for
just being in my life in general in the
back to the video I feel like that's a
bit truncated how do we go from student
films in Boston to LA
okay well some steps may have been
missed here yeah yeah okay so Boston has
a very small tight-knit little Film
Community yep a lot of independent film
shorts music videos features and then
some studio features go there and it's a
small Market it's um you could be a big
fish in a small pond in Boston if you're
decent you get your experience you find
out what you are what you aren't on
camera you build up your reels your
demos and three years in acting I had a
lot under my belt I had action reels
that I developed my stunt work
capabilities
um I get to practice a lot I get to [__]
around a little bit and just find out
what I can be on camera I developed
dramatic jobs comedy chops
um you know and and then when I moved to
LA I had demos lined up I had experience
I had confidence yeah and so when I came
to La I didn't underestimate the numbers
of people out here the numbers of actors
but I had a lot of faith in myself that
I could find some work in this town and
I didn't let it scare me I didn't let
those numbers deter me and so I came
here because you had done it right I
think that's the easiest way to people
asking me what the boxing match if I was
nervous and I kept saying no because I
had done so much that I was like I've
been doing this for so long for the last
three months that whatever will be will
be and I'm just confident in whatever's
in my brain will be like and if you're
prepared you kind of can't be nervous
exactly I wasn't nervous and what I did
was I set really small attainable goals
yeah a lot of people come out here on a
bus and they're like I'm gonna get
famous yeah and if it doesn't happen
within a year
a lot of people yeah and they leave and
they say well that didn't work out that
wasn't my goal my goal was literally
this I wanted to be able to say that for
one year in Los Angeles
I supported myself solely on acting what
you know maybe whether it was
commercials music videos short films I
didn't care I wanted to support myself
as an actor and if that happened and
then after a couple years it was really
tough I could go home and say hey I did
that and so when that did happen at one
point I just kept on going and I said
hey let's try this for another year
let's try this for another year and I
just was grinding it is a grind out here
it's a hustle yeah but you learn a lot
throughout that journey and I gotta say
it's been a decade now in L.A and a lot
of the people that I know that are
really successful out here
they usually have one thing in common
not looks not Talent
persistence
they simply stayed yeah and you know
like a a friend of mine used to say that
opportunity
is like a carousel your opportunity it
comes around ever so often you have to
be prepared for it and when it's right
in front of you you gotta recognize it
and jump yeah and that's it I definitely
think it's
easy for like I can only speak to
content creation but I imagine there are
parallels with acting here it's easy for
someone to Aspire for fame and then be
miserable because that is the most
unrealistic goal of all time like there
are a lot of people who are content
creators who are like it's my goal to
get a thousand followers by the end of
the year and I'm always like no no
focus on
you want to make a new podcast by the
end of the year you want to release a
video a week for the rest of the year
don't focus on how many followers you
have or how much money you have because
that's not up to you
the stuff you make is up to you right
but the results actually kind of aren't
you have to enjoy whatever you pursuing
it doesn't even have to be acting or
content create whatever it is you have
to enjoy the journey in the process
because if you don't you you're going to
become a a disgruntled
you know like you know what I'm saying
yeah you have to enjoy you have to enjoy
the ups and downs and realize that that
is that is that comes with the territory
that's all you have to grind and just
and you have to be prepared for the
hardships and the obstacles and I didn't
let that get me down sure I hit
Financial Rock Bottom two three times
and I I was almost ready to go home
stayed and I just did what I had to do
and people in my life supported me
throughout the whole time and I'm
grateful every day of my life but um
what we're doing it is tough It's you
have to be partially insane a little bit
insane yeah to want to do what we do
but you know keeps us going as a passion
totally yeah and I I guess when you
first moved to LA was it just passion
that was driving you was it
like a certain kind of job that you
wanted to book like what was the
aspiration outside of work did you have
an end goal at all
I honestly I just set small attemptible
goals I love that it's and I I think
it's important for mental health when
you're doing stuff like this
um to
really like pat yourself on the back and
celebrate those small goals and if you
can reach them weekly little tiny things
you can see the progress you can see the
incremental progress and even if it's
tiny it's still progress totally and
it's like okay I did this what what's
next what's the next little thing I can
do and that's why
I yes I'm all about also shooting for
the stars I don't think there's anything
wrong with that but it's like if you
don't happen to hit that goal way up
there it's you know it's gonna it can
Crush you totally and he's like what did
I just do for the past five years I
never reached that goal
and I tried to be careful with that I
think that's very smart what was the
work that you were doing when you first
moved to LA what kind of things were you
booking when you first moved commercials
wow commercials what kind
I was really good at the walk and talk
type where you're like walking down the
streets like hey guys check out some new
car insurance like hey it's not like
this one it's really that you know I was
um I got really good with commercials
just because I have a
you know I'm just like a jovial type
person and uh and I have the honest eyes
allegedly and look that's not what I
came to LA to do but commercials pay the
bills yeah
um if you Google me somehow you'd maybe
find like a bunch of these old ones I
want to find them now yeah I feel
compelled uh people have tagged me like
you know the the fans that I have from
Resident Evil and the video game stuff
that I do they're finding like these old
things that I've done that like is that
Nick in this like English as a second
language training video when he was like
18 years old I'm like that's so funny
and I get a little embarrassed but you
know what though that was part of my
journey and it it kept me afloat it kept
my bills paid and it kept me out of a
job I didn't want to do yeah and that
was one of my goals was I said I just
want to act and make some money if I can
support myself and so commercials a lot
of independent short films music videos
for sure some indie features I you know
I did a little bit of everything how did
you bridge the gap from doing all of
that out to getting into video games
okay so I was doing a fan film for uh
Hunger Games when Mockingjay was coming
out okay uh that a fan film was a big
action piece and everything I got to
play one of the guys with the bow and
arrow there uh Hawthorne cool and I met
uh someone you might know America Young
do you know her she she has an
illustrious career in video games okay
and so I was acting with her and I was
just saying hey what do you mostly do
out here and she said I'm a video game
actress that's mostly what I do voice
over and stuff and stunts I was like
that's you act in video games I didn't
even know that was a thing I didn't know
what motion capture was and she goes
yeah I've been in like 30 Games Call of
Duty all that stuff and right then a
light bulb went off I was like wow
that's cool what do I do where do I go
like who do I talk to and she she got me
started a little bit she's like you can
contact these Studios or whatever and
for like a year I was cold emailing all
these Studios these casting directors no
one got back to me I've done so much
cold emailing in my time it like
comforts me whenever I hear anybody else
say that they did no legitimately like
when I started out writing it was a lot
of cold emailing and getting no
responses I applied a job at IGN seven
times before I actually got a job there
and that was like over and over and over
again cold emails no experience at the
start just kept doing it until somebody
finally accepted me oh so you're saying
persistence got you persistence
um so you're a prime example
uh colimos can border on harassment to
be clear he has a fine line between
persistence and harassment but look at
you now yeah fine line guys yeah walk
down don't harass people but um so
anyways the the moral of that story is
it didn't work yeah for me that didn't
work and I nearly kind of gave up and I
said you know I'm pumping all this
energy into this it's not really working
maybe that's not for me
one day I saw uh on Actors Access a
public submission for auditions for
Resident Evil 2 remake it went public
normally one of the past video games
they're very private internal yeah they
go to big casting directors yada yada
now I didn't have an agent and I saw
this thing I I quickly submitted because
I thought it was a fan film I thought it
was a student film I just saw Resident
Evil 2 that game came out
1998. it's amazed that they did that
they did that and they broke NDA because
they it wasn't even a code name so I
submitted to this thing and I said hey
big fan of Resident Evil I'd love to
audition for Leon and
uh I get the audition back it's like you
have an audition for this on next
Wednesday and I looked at it I'm like
what is this thing and I looked and it
said this is the actual motion capture
for the remake of the video game and
this is Leon Kennedy and I'm like
oh my God and I I poured my heart out I
can't believe that's how that happened
more so more messages I said uh thank
you so much a huge fan blah blah I
prepped my ass off for weeks I I had
friends help me um with uh how to prep
this audition this was my life I this
was my one opportunity and I knew the
games inside and out because I started
playing in 1998 and I got the first
audition I nailed it I got a call back
and after the call back I nailed that
one too and I did something that an
actor should maybe possibly never do um
and I I wrote a big email and I asked
the casting director to please share
that with the director it was not
begging for the role at all not biggie
I'm not like that
I poured my heart out and I just told
them what the franchise means to me and
I said I understand this world I
understand the characters I said I am
not the only guy that can play this role
I said but if you give me a chance I
will give you everything and I will give
you a hell of a rendition of Leon
what do they say it was very bold yeah
that is very bold I got the role and
they said they actually took that letter
into consideration I think I would too
in casting I think if I got
an email yeah you're right that Peggy
would be off-putting and seems
unprofessional and like someone you
don't want to work with it was very
particularly worded it was very careful
there's a thing about
video games and how long you have to
work on them for right where if somebody
can give you an indication that they're
going to be a good team player and
collaborative and passionate about a
project that's going to sell them
probably beyond what an audition tape
can just do because like as actors you
guys have to work together for such a
long time with directors and writers and
animators all on these tiny weird
looking sets you need to know someone's
like good for the team right like that's
an important thing I hear that every
time yeah they don't want to cast jerks
totally they might be the best actor in
the room but if they're jerks that's a
lot of negative points yeah it's not
worth it it's it's too much time and too
much money but that's almost with any
career it's not just just with acting I
mean look at these jobs that you like
you have for instance like you don't
want to work with a top like in a toxic
environment with people you just hate I
mean that's gonna affect the work it's
true it's a very good team shout out to
Santa Monica Studio shout out to Samurai
Studios
so you book the job yeah you become Leon
then what what did you do did you go out
and potty like what's your first
response to actually booking it my knees
went weak I was painting a house when
that happened nice I'm a painter as well
I just like it's therapeutic and I
almost fell off the ladder I'm like
that's very Leon if you actually bought
a lot of stuff now I remember that it
was a it was a big moment in my life
because Resident Evil has been my
favorite franchise since 98 yeah and
when she called me up she said hey would
you like to be a leon I was like I said
are you [__] kidding me she goes no
I'm not [__] kidding you you want to
be Leon say yes yeah I guess I I I'm
busy that day you might have to wash my
hair I gotta go to CVS Dad yeah sorry I
need toothpaste
um
it's just it's I don't know I can't even
describe it to you it's just like I've
been in a surreal state for a very long
time because it's not often that a
performer gets to work on something that
he
is his favorite thing
um the only thing that would Top This is
to like get maybe like get in a time
machine and go back to be in Terminator
2. great film and you know maybe be cast
as like Kyle Reese or something like
that that'd be pretty cool well he
wasn't in two maybe John Wayne or
something yeah yeah yeah off Terminator
2 when that gets made by Capcom you will
figure it out it's not gonna happen
um who's the first person you told
first person I told my little brother
it's very nice yeah because your
brother's uh I don't remember if we
mentioned it here you've played the
games through together right like your
whole life yeah yeah I introduced my
little brother to video games when he
was five years old and I started him
the right way with Mario nice because he
had to yeah um and then I introduced him
to Resident Evil when he was nine and so
I was babysitting him I was babysitting
him one day and he was playing Mario
Sunshine at the time probably and I said
I was like Dave do you want to play like
a big boy game and he's like yeah it's
like okay we're playing Resident Evil 4
because it just came out and he had
nightmares for like three weeks worth it
worth it and he fell in love and that's
like it's now his favorite franchise too
that's awesome so what did he say when
he told him
uh he flipped out
he flipped out and he almost didn't
believe it yeah that's yeah that that is
incredible so yeah you start work I'm
trying not to make this like too Leon
specific but it's obviously a big deal
for you what was it like working as that
character or becoming that character as
such a big fan of the franchise
well there's a there's a lot of games
that are multi-generational and go on
for decades and look at like Final
Fantasy is a good example like you know
and characters get portrayed by so many
different actors over the years and so
right away I mean there was the Elation
that I got the role but then right away
because I'm so familiar with all the
performances that I grew up with there
was the pressure yeah and I said holy
[__] I've got some shoes to fill
um the uh the actor for the original
Resident Evil 4 for Leon he's a hero of
mine a hero and I I've got to tell him
that in person that he's one of the
reasons I wanted to start acting in the
first place was to I was listening to
his performance and I used to just
Daydream with my little brother and say
it would be awesome to be in these games
one day and like actually be a character
because of Leon
you know and so the pressure
I try not to psych myself out and uh
kudos to Capcom who just really just
said listen just trust yourself like you
don't need to be or copy anything
we cast you because of the essence that
we just think your personality is close
to this version of Leon and just go for
it you know and so I listened to them uh
you know worked out as a DieHard fan did
you have trouble separating yourself
from the previous version
no your brain just didn't go there
I was I was so familiar with everything
um
I really just trusted them and the
directing yeah uh the director was a
brilliant guy and
I was just trying to enjoy it you know
enjoy the scenario and again I
understand the world and I was just
living out a dream you know it was
pretty much like living in an action
movie like an action horror movie and so
I didn't think about it too hard
he he really does does a good job of
bringing you right into the moment and
he would just say how would if this was
happening in real life
what would be going on inside of you how
would you react yeah with the you know
the script that we have you can change
you know have Liberties to change it and
whatever but how would you react and he
just gave us that freedom and so I
wasn't thinking about too hard how long
did you work on it for
Jesus on and off many different sessions
about two and a half years it's a long
time and I don't remember was Leonia
first video game
technically yes
um yes yes but you've done a bunch more
since then right how did that you go
from
Leon to now you do like a lot of pcapp
and a lot of mocap right like is that
would you say that's like your bread and
butter at this point
I would say yeah mocap yeah so you
successfully broke into that industry
like how do you expand Beyond just one
character because I know that can happen
to a lot of actors where you just kind
of get stuck playing the one guy voicing
the characters is actually that's
tougher to do that a lot um I do a lot
of just Bodywork motion capture and
that's just interchangeable you can work
on many games at many times uh work on B
Teams doing stunts and everything like
that sounds so cool though like yeah
yeah Leon's cool and all yeah but like
you get to just be bodies of characters
like I feel like that's awesome and
different characters and everything you
know I work uh on and off like Apex
Legends mobile
um you get to play a lot of the male
protagonists there like the people you
can choose they have different body
shape sizes different moves different
personalities
um and any given day you're on set
you're playing like five six different
guys
um one guy's a 300 pound Samoan or like
you know skinny robot guy with robot
legs I don't know
um it's just fun I have a big stunt
background and so I I did about maybe
four to five weeks on like Medal of
Honor call it um Medal of Honor above
and beyond I've played hundreds of Nazis
in that game that you kill and blow up
and you know it's just very different
types of work and I just get to bring a
lot of my physicality into roles like
that what does that work actually look
like as a day job like if you're going
in there to be blowing up as a Nazi
what is that obviously you have the PC
suit on well the mocap suit yeah
um and people like throwing stuff at you
like what does it look like to record a
bunch of death animations oh it's so
different uh a lot of props
sometimes they do throw tennis balls at
you that would be a grenade and you
gotta react to that
um you show up to a shot list I guess of
like every single death animation that
you have to do that day and sometimes
there are like hundreds and you've got
to take like a head shot from the back
headshot from the front headshot from
the side 45 and wow and you're just
hitting the mat hitting the mat
exploding you get pulled with wire work
and stuff uh is that fun or is it just
painful it sounds fun it is fun
um and the next day you are dead yeah
you you can't even move your neck I mean
so I've learned from a lot of I wouldn't
call myself a stunt person I'm an action
actor who's very stunt capable with
limitations
I have some stunt friends who are
absolute pros at what they do and
um I've learned a lot from them of how
to keep yourself safe yeah how to make
it look real how to sell these things
even for the warm-ups I was on set one
time and for all the Whiplash that you
give yourself to make it look painful
your neck is not used to doing that on a
daily basis I don't care who you are and
literally the warm-ups you stretch your
whole body you warm up you get the blood
flowing and then you you take your hand
and you you literally just give yourself
Whiplash like this just to get your neck
used to that you know
stuff like that and then the next day
you are still your whole body is just
like I can't mean it's so cool though
because I feel like this is a thing that
like we know exists in video games but I
feel like people rarely consider that
it's a human doing it and that is why
stunts need to have their own category
yeah again I'm not a stunt person I have
the utmost respect for the stunt people
look at all these games that win game of
the year they'd be nothing without the
stunt teams and they seldom they just
don't get the recognition that they
deserve yeah all these people that you
kill you guys are you playing Resident
Evil 4 you're playing dead space or
whatever those
that AI those enemies that you're
killing they are Mo capped Often by
people yeah and they don't realize it no
and I feel like like they just don't get
spoken about at all like they don't yeah
and it's too bad and it's so important
too because like we can complain about
death animations or enemies feeling
stiff or like the AI is not right but
sometimes that is just animation it's
humans having to like throw themselves
to the ground around our entertainment
yeah and it feels good killing them so
yeah definitely so how big of a job is
that like if you're oh hi this again the
guy who gets killed as a Nazi 100 times
is that like a week of work like how
long are you doing that kind of thing
for depends on the project I guess it
really depends on the project yeah and
and sometimes these games are they're
updated constantly that's what a lot of
games are doing now um I got the great
opportunity to work on
um a great team that did so much of the
updating on the Call of Duty games in
the past I'd say since 2020 so Modern
Warfare when that came out in maybe
2020 or so yeah cold war and then
Vanguard I worked with this great team
uh directed by Macau Vega and I was
lucky enough to jump on those teams and
every day was something different maybe
like an update trailer for season three
or um new melee kills or something like
that and I would just work with these
really talented group people there and
every day was just totally different you
never knew what you were going to do
sometimes they didn't even know they
would get this new shot list and say
okay today we have to do some trailer
work and also um some new melee kills
and then we could do this big explosion
scene with a helicopter it's like all
right great you just make it happen and
it's very inventive it's creative it's
collaborative and it's physical yeah I
bet so you know I like the P CAP and
everything I like the voice over but
that stuff is also fun to me because
it's like living out an action movie
how much of your like professional time
is dedicated to staying in shape for
stuff like that I have to so I love
Oreos
as I get older I'm almost 40. I have to
work out all the time I'm at the gym
three three days a week four days a week
I run about 20 miles a week damn but I
have to do this because I'm I'm getting
my joints are getting older I take
glucosamine I have to take care of my
body because my my career depends on it
yeah
um I have to be in Tip-Top shape I have
to be able to jump up and grab a ladder
you know it's like yeah and climb that
thing and look Nimble while doing it do
the stunts because I have so much fun
doing it so I have to what's the
craziest stunt you've done for a video
game
oh that's a good question
um craziest done or your favorite either
is good oh oh okay all right uh getting
uh for for Medal of Honor
um
above and beyond
I got I was riding this uh fake
motorcycle and I had this uh wire
attached to me and the scene was that
he's riding in if uh the protagon the
player if he blows him up with a grenade
it's kind of like the Indiana Jones
scene where the motorcycle just goes and
he flips over the thing and he does a
double front flip
the thing damn and so they literally
yanked me in the air and I did two front
flips and landed on my back
that was super cool probably 15 feet in
there like that [__] was fun and we did
a bunch of different takes so one is uh
you go the front flips then off to the
side and then off to this side and stuff
so I'm just getting blown up all day
that sounds awesome what's the fake
motorbike look like I imagine you're
like holding something that did you then
like have to throw it when they pull you
it's some kind of like uh that maybe you
sit on an Apple box and yeah they give
you something in front something like
handlebars just make it look like a
motorcycle and it looks like you're you
know you know going out of control and
then they just they call it out three
two one explosion and they yoink it and
you just gotta like just let go of
yourself and just trust that
everything's gonna be fine yeah I was
gonna say that has to be a lot of trust
right sorry because
you don't have any option to restrain
like you literally have to be like this
is an explosion I have to trust that
everybody else has my back while I am
acting out an explosion that's carrying
All of Me and again so kudos to the
teams that do this they are the best
Professionals in the industry yeah and
safety is number one and I trust them
they've done this a million times and
the last thing they want is for anyone
to get hurt of course they want it to
look good but safety and so I just I
just trust and you just let go of that
control and hopefully you get it in one
or two takes if not you're gonna just
hurt extra the next day that's just the
way it goes that's so cool this is a
facet of uh video game acting that I've
never spoken about on this particular
podcast before
if there's somebody watching at home
who's like oh I want to do that how do
they get into the stunt side of motion
capture
that's tricky too
um though I will ask you that for every
layer of it like if you had advice now
for how to get into it aside from
persistence what do you what do you tell
people who want to act in video games
that's a good question don't let the
people now
the pressure's on
[__]
um
I mean this is I get asked this a lot
and you could write a book on this it's
it's it's a long answer but the short
answer is train
did you go to school no okay I I would
say that my training was on the
battlefield and I had the um I would say
50 of people what I've had on the show
have not been to school the other 50
have which is super interesting
I I think formal training is excellent
and I've had a lot of friends that that
thrive with it
but I was fortunate to start in a small
market like Boston yeah and before I
ever came to La I had already been in
maybe 60 projects yeah that was my
training I made so many mistakes I
learned what I was what I wasn't on
camera
um I made my mistakes I learned I had
comedy chops you know I I learned I've
trained in projects and
I would say I'm a huge advocate of
classes so take classes learn your craft
learn as much as you can get into
workshops
read books on the subject
Network learn to network be likable on
set if you get these little
opportunities I don't care if it's a
student film just don't be a dick yeah
and you never know these people that you
work with along the way like you build a
relationship you build a um a reputation
for that guy that's really fun on set
he's a good actor but he's also fun to
work with and he's collaborative and he
has ideas
just you have to want it for the right
reasons I think the most important thing
I tell people want it for the right
reasons set the small attainable goals
and just go from there it's to get into
voiceover and video games it's a very
very competitive market I'm not trying
to deter anybody it's realistic I'm just
trying to tell you I'm a very realistic
guy I'm not idealistic and if you are an
idealistic thinker this might not be the
career path for you
um
you know and I'll balance uh have good
balance to the first few years of my
career I did not have a healthy balance
and yeah it consumed me
and I would not advocate for that it's
hard not to like to to not be consumed
by that stuff when you first start out
so
uh the advice is
train get as much experience as you can
obviously we've spoken about persistence
yeah
um I think student films is a really
great way to get started because I I
think I've spoken about this on a couple
of podcasts but all of my writing
experience to begin with is volunteer
all of it to just get the experience
same thing learn what I was and wasn't
good at yep
have feedback from additives that's a
big thing is just doing stuff so that
people can give you feedback like off
the internet like people who are
actually working in Creative Fields can
give you feedback so you can learn what
is Transformer you can improve yeah and
that stuff is invaluable like you
gotta collaborate with as many people as
you can I think
um but for the motion capture or stunt
stuff specifically that seems like a
very distinct Niche how do you enter
that
honestly to
to be honest
okay
the reason I don't call myself a stunt
man is because the the professionals
that I have been lucky enough to work
with actual stunt people they dedicate
their lives to that they are in a gym
like five six days a week learning new
skills training with people learning
martial arts disciplines weapon um uh
weapon work you know Firearms they are
just in it all the time and
and they know the the stunt coordinators
and that's what that's what their whole
Pursuit is and that's where that's where
they get the big jobs yeah for me
there's this very very small niche in in
the um I would say the video game world
but also the TV and film where they need
action actors
someone who can deliver a couple lines
and do a stunt or someone who could do a
whole scene or be a lead who can also do
some stunts or just be very physical
and that's kind of where I got into
video games and I I thrived a bit is
because I can I can do both I have a lot
of limitations with stunts
I'm not good with any martial arts I'm
not flexible I can't do high kicks
around houses I can't do any of that
[__] I'm just I'm like a brawler that
you could you could toss me across the
room and I'll be good
such a funny thing to know about
yourself like to be consciously aware
that that's a thing you can say about
yourself is amazing well you know what I
grew up like really one of my favorite
characters in cinematic history is John
McLean in Die Hard one he got his ass
kicked yeah he wasn't he wasn't a like a
Kung Fu expert or something he wasn't
like Bruce Lee he was just a cop who
just threw fists it's endearing it's
endearing he was a real guy and now you
know I I wanted to be that and so I got
good at just taking hits and I can make
I can sell pain really well and but also
um my good friend James Poirier uh
fantastic director for a film I did a
lot of short films with him he's one of
the guys who showed me early on in
Boston that I can be an action guy he
said you can you can do this and he
taught me um some hand-to-hand combat
and he taught me firearms and I'll be
damned if that's not a huge part of
where my career went
is because of the films I did and I got
to be an action hero in his films with
10K 10K Productions of my buddy Travis
Tyler like we just kicked ass and I saw
myself as I can be that
and it helped with my confidence going
to La yeah you know yeah you kind of
just need somebody to believe in you to
be honest it's a big thing every step of
the way they believed in me and then I
believed in myself when I went to LA and
so part of the reason I got Resident
Evil is because I could move like like a
cop I could handle firearms and that was
a huge thing is they wanted someone who
knew Firearms interesting so what did
your um like with that in mind what did
your audition for Resident Evil look
like
um so definitely scene work yeah and
that's what I had a lot of friends help
me with and um
and then even James was helping me with
the physical stuff they said you're
going to be doing Walk Cycles Run cycles
that was in the audition persons oh yeah
wow oh yeah they they had me do things
as not super complicated but
um going into like a tactical forward
roll and then coming out of it on a knee
and drawing an audition in the audition
wow on mats and then like we did one
whereas like a Ford tumble so you
literally just like you throw yourself
into the air into a roll grab the gun
and aim at a zombie and kill him no so
we did some physical [__] just and then
even yelling uh you know like I'll meet
you at the police station just to see
you like how physical you can be in
those kinds of scenarios I've heard that
yelling when it comes to acting can be
really difficult what was it someone was
telling me that interesting a lot of
even like very accomplished Screen
Actors try to come into video games and
really mess up yelling
um I don't remember what the actual note
that they had was unfortunately I would
love to know this yeah I wish I could it
was something about like the way that
you project when you're like miked up
immediately in front of you has to be
different to the way that a lot of
Screen Actors know to project something
like that I wish I could remember the
note that there was this whole thing
about it I'm sorry I've let you down no
text the director and be like what was
that thing saying about yelling also
people have trouble keeping accents when
yelling that's definitely a thing
I think if you're doing an accent you
have to yell in character that can be
really hard luckily Leon is not
Australian because I would have never
got the job because I do not have been
here for accents I don't feel like you
have much of a Bostonian accent though I
don't but I can turn it on if you want
um nice no I I never had a Boston accent
really especially when I was acting even
in Boston a lot of people did not want
Regional accents and Boston accent is it
can be annoying and so when I moved to
LA of course I just dropped it however
once in a blue moon if I saw a casting
for a commercial or anything that said
hey we want like a maybe East Coast
Boston guy oh my God I would turn it on
yeah that's kind of nice to be able to
to switch into it if you need to yeah
have that in your back pocket
um so after the audition process for
Leon yeah
I don't even know if you're allowed to
answer this so if you can't it's fine
but when you're doing this amount of
physical work for a role do you have to
sign like a [__] ton of waivers like how
are they legally with stunt stuff or did
they just have a ton of like stunt
coordinators on set like what are the
precautions to make sure actors are kept
safe in these situations actually in in
the Resident Evil projects um they
didn't let me do it a ton of my own
stunts uh they don't want you to get
hurt I mean even if you can do it if you
sprain an ankle or break your ankle God
forbid that's like the whole project
that's kind of it and so in Resident
Evil 4
well actually I shouldn't say that when
I did infinite darkness in Japan the
Japanese team was hilarious because they
let me do so many of my own stunts they
barely even vetted me and they just I
you know these crazy setups with the
wires and everything um I just said hey
can I do that and they said
that's awesome okay let's do it and
luckily I could do it all but um with
the the games Resident Evil 2 and
Resident Evil 4 uh resi 4 was way more
heavy on the action
um I got to implement some of my
physicality with that and they they
spliced in with some crazy stunt work
with these teams that are just Pros like
I said and those guys made me look
really badass and so they did a hell of
a job
um and so we just spliced
performances together and we have what
we have how many people if you know
actually make up Leon in our A4 a lot
um I mean geez there's the like
obviously we have you know animes
developers writers all that but I mean
in terms of like the character of Leon
physically and your voice
I imagine that's still a team it is so I
mocapped all the cutscenes yep uh the
in-game as you're controlling Leon like
we did today
um as you're controlling him that was
done by uh a Japanese actor uh stunt
performer he did all moves the
roundhouse kicks and all that stuff the
flips uh then
stunts so maybe maybe two stunned people
did all of Leon's uh crazy stuff the
in-game actor that's three myself maybe
maybe four people so then for that group
of people do you guys have to get
together
and make sure it's consistent
no uh watch each other no I I think the
animation can obviously cover a lot of
that animation can cover a lot of that
and I think it Capcom just does a really
good job of just making him feel
cohesive yeah
it just works it uh strongly agree you'd
never tell but it is to have the Insight
but like you know multiple people make
up so many different facets of every
game like it's it honestly people
watching this like if you guys knew
exactly what goes into making a video
game you have no idea it's yeah it's
insane if you know you know it's a lot
it's a lot and that's why hundreds and
that's why the credits of so long these
days like a Papyrus stroll down to you
know bottom of the ocean were you
affected by covid making Ari for remake
yes what did that do to the industry for
you
I almost was not able to do the motion
capture for Leon because of kobit and
they were thinking about just having my
voice in it and I was crossing my
fingers that I'd be able to do it and we
just made it happen
um yeah there's been limitations I think
they were just lifted
they were like last week like last week
yeah I mean look that
the pandemic affected so much with
motion capture video games a lot of
projects put on Hiatus
um just everything uh the limitations on
set where you couldn't have like
multiple people in the volume for more
than 15 minutes a day I know like EA had
the really strict rules and I was acting
a lot with EA but masks they were timing
how much interaction you had with
another character per day wow you can
only total 15 minutes damn and so the
second a take was done you throw the
mask back on separate wow it was pretty
intense yeah what does that do for stuff
like chemistry
you just work through it yeah there were
there were projects where I was
literally directed by a by an iPad
screen that was on a Segway and the
director was on this and so the Segway
would just follow us and just turn like
a little robot man and he would watch
our performance and he would direct us
remotely from a Segway from another room
very impressive but it also
but we do we have to do and some great
projects were made clearly at the time
yeah surprisingly a large amount like
the video game industry was halted
pretty significantly a big part of the
problem I've spoken about this before
but um the file sizes are a really big
issue that I think a lot of people don't
realize when walking remotely in Game
Dev yeah file sizes are a massive
problem I never even thought about that
yeah it's a massive problem with
everybody's internet making everything
so slow and you can't upload the things
that you need to is like really halted
the industry in ways I think a lot of
people didn't realize it's hard to
transfer big old files so either
compress like everything pretty much
which is time consuming in itself well
yeah and because everything
um at least in AAA I mean I'm it's
probably as well for the most part uh
things have to be so encrypted so
everything's secure that you generally
can only remote into a server and
security and yeah it's it's complicated
uh the it teams in game that freely done
a great job over the last few years see
that's the side of the games that I
don't even understand yeah I'm not
involved with it I mean even like our
operations team the people who just run
the office they're all so incredible
well it's just yeah it's so many people
who are so important to just making sure
that people have food at the office is
important like it's it's a lot of people
making sure video games function for
sure it's so crazy I I hope to be
working your video games like my entire
life and if there comes a day where my
body just can't handle it anymore I want
to be in Game Dev oh yeah what did you
do what would you do rather sorry I
don't even know there's plenty of jobs I
don't know a lot of people production's
really fun yeah the voice directing is
really fun one uh I have friends who've
done started in voice acting and then
one in a motion capture and pcap and now
do like cinematic directing which is
also a really cool one that's cool but
honestly if I had to choose one thing I
think it would be you could do all
uh yeah maybe it's just very time
consuming I hit that you hear that sorry
it's uh no that's that's too time
consuming I think but I would like to be
in Game Dev
um in gameplay design
okay that's what I do actually is
technically design
really yeah I'm a writer but I'm on the
design team I didn't know that yeah so
the ride is at Santa Monica Studio a
part of the design division which means
that um
part of what I get to do I have to be
very vague in how I speak about this but
is be like
what if this encounter looked like this
could we do this in gameplay and that's
part of writing yeah it's really fun
it's really really cool I don't I can't
take credit for any of it because it
goes through a million people who then
go we can do that but they listen to
your ideas they do but they make them
better or they tell you they're stupid
or they tell you it's too expensive
um it is a really fun part that's okay
because when I play new games
I I look at that and I'm like wow that's
really cool that's cool oh I would have
done it this way like that's the way my
brain works and oh I just think that's
fascinating and it's cool I think I can
make I would love to develop like an
indie game one day all right dude I
believe in you do you want to do it
the problem is you have to have a
programmer
you heard it from her we're going to
start next week we're going to develop
an indie game so this podcast I have
player watch listen is with um Troy
Baker uh Austin winter who's a composer
and then Mike Bethel he's a program
slash game director and we've spoken
about making a game together and the
reason we haven't is that Mike is always
like I'm the only programmer
that means I'm making a game and you're
all given ideas like doing all
programming is is hard that's it I would
actually like to learn programming it's
a thing that I feel like I like I used
to do a little bit of just like really
basic Java but I would like to now that
I work around it even closer like to
just like maybe take a course and be
like how do I code but isn't that
something you can't just dabble in like
don't you have to
so bad at math yeah but I would like to
like you can write pretty basic code
depending on what you're trying to do
right like in theory if you gave me a
few years I could write a sufficient
text-based Adventure like I could do
that um if I sat down and did it anyway
that's a separate podcast
um uh to give you a really broad
question I love asking people this
question
um I'm gonna make you do it outside of
Leon what's your favorite thing that
you've worked on in your entire career
as an actor outside of Resident Evil oh
that's easy
um so a whole another facet of what I do
we haven't touched upon uh you could say
it's an actor host Builder um so I've
been traveling the world for the past
three and a half years and we've been
I've been on this program called the
fixers and what we do is we we help
very special non-profit organizations
build a community project that they're
trying to get off the ground no way and
what has stopped them is maybe like they
just don't have the resources the money
the funding the Manpower you name it uh
the challenges in the environment and we
choose to partner with them we go in we
help them we give them the resources
they need we go build with their
Community not for them we we rely on
their local help as well we break
through the language barrier and we
build projects with them I have no idea
you did that that's awesome I've been a
builder almost all my life I mean I my
fir one of my first Hobbies ever was
building with Legos and when I was a kid
when people would say what do you want
to be when you grow up architect nice a
builder was my uh number one answer no
way that's awesome very nice and I just
I never pursued it professionally per se
but I have about 15 years experience in
the trades so I've worked with
carpenters framers contractors painters
I worked for AAA as a light duty Road
mechanic it's so I have because my dad's
Blue Collar like Jack of all trades and
so growing up I emulated him and so I
was pursuing acting and Hospitality in
my 20s
and one day I saw a casting call for
they wanted a a host Builder an actual
Builder and they said you want to travel
the world and I got that opportunity and
I said yeah let's do this and so I've
been I've been to like 35 different
countries building stuff building stuff
all around the world dude that's awesome
wow I just got back from the British
Virgin Islands with them I was there two
weeks ago wow how cool I mean yeah
that's very different to acting but what
a what a fun thing to get to do it's
hosting and so also like part of the
show I'd say it's like um 40 of of it
covers the build and the challenges yeah
it's all real and then 60 is about the
community and in the story of like why
is this project important for this
community in Ecuador you know and it's a
very heartfelt show it's all real and
why can't people watch it
um it's on a very small Network on the
the BYUtv Network very small but
um you can watch it for free online and
you don't even need to subscribe to
anything it's uh just with a URL
that's amazing yeah wow very cool that's
a great answer that I definitely did not
expect
um next broad question uh what's your
favorite thing about your job
hmm okay
favorite thing about my job is
when I started acting uh let's let's
rewind for a second when I was a kid I
used to watch movies Often by myself
and back then I didn't really understand
why but the answer is I really
was affected I like when movies would
affect me and I could only pay attention
to to that
if I was by myself and I'd have someone
in my ear all the time I would pay
attention to the lighting and the acting
back then and the story and the emotions
and I just sucked it in
and when I started acting maybe I asked
myself like why do you want to do this
like what
what would make you happy with acting
and I wanted to be able to affect people
without not necessarily ever having met
them
yeah it's a lot of power to affect an
audience make them think about something
twice have them go home and say hey that
scene you know that was really powerful
yeah I just want it simply to do that
and so I get to do that with the the
building show I mean these stories of
these people like we helped them and
it's one of the most fulfilling things
I've ever done in my entire life it's
changed everything about me and uh and
even with the video games
um we hear all the time that
performances affect someone's day or
help them through a tough time in their
life important part about being human I
think is having the power to affect
people yeah and this is just a really
unique opportunity to do that because
these games and the shows and everything
it reaches an audience of you know
bigger than you'd ever imagine and
you'll never meet these people but you
still affect them totally that's why I
do it that's very nice
um how do you feel about like the amount
of players who've got their hands on
resume before is it daunting or just
cool I mean I I knew it was going to
happen yeah the the game has a legacy
the franchise has a legacy
multi-generational
um
it's like with Resident Evil 2 when that
came out I was not expecting that kind
of exposure I didn't I didn't I didn't
know what that was like I'd never
reached that many people and had people
comment and you know all the stuff
online I was never in the public eye
and with this one this time around I
knew what to expect and I knew what it
was going to be and you kind of just
gotta go for it uh you feel a little
sense of responsibility to do the
character Justice again he's been
portrayed by so many Fantastic actors
a little responsibility like don't [__]
this up give it everything you've got
because this is the one chance you have
Joe this is it this could be it for you
you know and for this is my favorite
project of all time it's like this is
the only time it's gonna happen for me
so that's it you just you just go for it
you dive in head first and good news
people really like it
allegedly it's uh
it's getting great reviews and yeah
Capcom just [__] nailed it they
really have nailed it yeah they nailed
it they knew it they knew the Legacy
yeah they've done such a good job with
all of these and also like giving a
Resurgence to survival horror Dead Space
wouldn't have been remade without any
throws Me Remix it's very cool
um another broad question what is the
most challenging thing about what you do
one of the biggest challenges
that's a really good one Lana she's good
she's really good
give me the tough one you've done this
before yeah I do ask everybody that
question to be fair it's one of my
favorites because again often get
different answers that's the hardest
thing
um let's see
bonus points if it's unexpected but I
understand I'm really landed on thick
now okay
I think I got one for you this is this
is personal I guess
for me I've been fortunate enough to say
that yes I've been more or less My Own
Boss
for the past that's a decade I haven't
really answered to anybody yep and one
big challenge for me has been I'd say
time management
and motivation maybe
um
I I'm a very motivated person very
self-motivated but maybe time management
like there there are sometimes months at
a time where I you know it's hard to
update the website you have this so this
whole list of things you can do as an
actor there's so many things and no
one's really holding your hand for it
you gotta learn you get to figure this
out that out in some months some times
of the year more productive than others
sometimes you're like listen I just I
was on the road for four months I just
want to [__] around for like six weeks
and play video games and not shave yeah
it's like sometimes I I could be just
more on top of things and be a better
manager of my own life
that is the hardest thing for me to get
really hold of I'm getting because you
could feel like I guess if you're not
working that you're on vacation but you
technically aren't yes like yes you can
be like well I just finished a job last
week but you could have a month off but
you still realistically should have a
regimen of nine to six to make sure that
you're still functioning yes that is
hard as your own manager it's like uh my
my next paycheck depends on me yeah and
only me and sometimes people say hey you
wanna you wanna come out to uh Vegas for
a weekend or you want to go camping for
three days during the week and it's just
like yeah sure yeah yeah I'll come up
and you could just do that and it gets
addicting it's like I can do anything I
want at any time and I can't just for
your own detriments and so I I think
finding a balance sometimes I'm a
workaholic when people my close friends
are like you need to slow down just
chill sleep in tomorrow and I'm like no
I gotta do I got and then like I'm a
very extreme guy yeah I'm a very like
opposite end of the Spectrum type guy in
the gray area yeah you know what I mean
yeah definitely because I'm the exact
same you catch yourself sometimes and
you work too hard why not I walk way too
hard vast majority of the time
um but then if I like get in a rut
restarting it can be hard like if I stop
making YouTube videos for a week I'm
like I don't [__] make one like it
like gets in this like Loop of oh
um but if I am doing it yeah it's it's
100 I get it like it's hard that's the
hardest thing I think yeah and I I have
trouble with um
working from home and making sure like
I'm allowed to technically on uh my
employment work whatever hours I want um
I try really hard to make sure that I
stick to a regular nine to six because
otherwise I'll be like why don't I write
at 1am because maybe that's when I feel
inspired or something and as a creative
you kind of have to follow that energy
into productive time which can be a
really complicated thing to do be like
if I don't feel like riding at 9am but I
have writing due at 12 I have to like it
has to be done then um that structure is
important for creativity in a way that I
you wouldn't think or that I wouldn't
have thought when I was a kid yeah but
you do need instruction there's a part
of me that misses structure I I haven't
worked for like let's say a company for
probably since maybe 20
2011. yeah
and it was kind of nice knowing exactly
where your next paycheck was going to be
and I've had tough years yeah and I've
had some very fortunate years and it's
just this up and down it's like the this
the sense of insecurity
is actually a bit enticing I'm a bit of
a masochist in a lot of ways and
it's interesting to me and it keeps me
on my toes it keeps me sharp knowing
that like hey if I want money in my bank
account I'm gonna go out there and get
this [__] and I get a hustle and grind
I think I've said this to a number of
actors who've been on this show too is
I feel like acting where insecurity is
concerned has to be so difficult because
you can put your all into an audition
and not even hear back that doesn't
happen in most other Industries and they
expect you to learn sides within 24
hours and get the character and and
memorize these you know do that for a
normal job interview and then you can
just never hear back from anybody and it
could have been that you were too tall
it like and you might be like what did I
do wrong in my performance and it
doesn't necessarily have anything to do
with you that maybe your hair was too
similar to someone else they cost like
it could be anything it seems like like
it'd be so hard not to internalize
rejection
it's the way that you look at it a long
time ago I just changed my relationship
with that and I just realized that
that's part of the game yeah because you
hear the stories of people who have made
it these A-list actors you've seen all
these big movies and they have similar
stories where they're like there was
like five years I couldn't get a call
back to save my life
they stuck with it that stubborn all
word persistence they just stuck with it
and it's when you accept that everybody
goes through that yeah the people who
get discovered off the streets they were
discovered one day and now they're big
that is like point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero one percent of the people
so those people to me they don't exist
they may as well not exist uh it's It's
a Grind and if again if you want to do
this you have to be insane I'm not
saying don't do it we're a little bit
just make sure you're insane
but it's a very high risk High reward
industry totally yeah you still get to
have a dream job you're still gonna have
dream job yeah um but I know that you
just started to Twitch Channel what do
you do outside of acting speaking of
making sure you keep yourself motivated
in off hours well I'm a I'm a creative
Pisces through and through I have a
million hobbies my mom used to call me
like she's she's like you're like a fly
Nick you're just like buzzing all around
at these Hobbies you're like why don't
you just pick one thing and try to get
good at it so I I mean I
I live a lot of lives I
you know I'm a blue collar at heart I'm
a builder I love building in my hands I
build um custom furniture live bed
furniture with like epoxy like table
tops and stuff
um bedside tables stuff like that um I'm
an artist so I do like graphite art
um I play guitar I write music I I have
a culinary degree I like to cook no way
so I have a lot of creative Outlets
creative Hobbies um I love playing video
games and I mean I was out of acting I
mean I've been playing them for over
three decades of my life and so I don't
know I'm just like uh I'm a mushroom I'm
a fun guy I have a lot of hobbies I
can't really sometimes I'm like crippled
with like what which one do I do though
because if I read the book now then I
can't do the language I've been trying
to learn and then I want to paint but
how am I gonna have time I have it's
game to finish I think I struggle with
that every weekend of what to do yeah
which help you to pick that's it's a
good thing it's a bad thing but People
Like Us never get bored never get bored
never been bored in my life you could
put me in a cardboard box for a week oh
yeah and I'll be content fine I'll be
good to go same I used to uh my mom
always tells the story about how my
parents packed up a house and we were
moving out and they were really worried
that I'd be super bored I would have
been like 506. you literally played in a
couple all I had was a ruler in a
cardboard box and I was fined for six
hours straight that's that's all it was
like that's right
literally that was a metaphor but I used
to make forts in cardboard boxes oh yeah
and uh it's just uh when people tell me
they're like oh I'm so bored I've
watched everything on Netflix I have
nothing else I'm like never been bored
it's not even one time that's like when
you look like to each his own and the
world takes all kinds to go around all
that stuff that is just a very different
human than me um yeah I could never get
bored when we started filming Resident
Evil 4 I had to quarantine in Vancouver
for 14 days and I could not leave this
this uh this Loft I couldn't leave
and a lot of my friends were like oh God
you're gonna go insane I'm like are you
kidding they could put me in there for
three months I'd be happy and I brought
my artwork I brought my Playstation I
finished Resident Evil eight that was
totally fine the thing that I had when I
was in my two week quarantine though
that I didn't expect was that by the end
of it because I was in a hotel room that
I wasn't allowed to leave like my
balcony we couldn't open doors there's a
lot um
uh it smelled really bad by the end yeah
that was not a thing I had considered
was how smelling a hotel room with no
windows and no clean is able to go in
there yeah is off to two weeks I was
like there's crumbs on the floor I can't
do anything about like I was just like
oh my God humans are terrible like it
just like
because we weren't allowed to clean them
because we couldn't actually take any
equipment so like I just spilled coffee
and I was like there it is well [__]
yeah that's here for 14 days I guess
it's just a wild experience but I did
finish Resident Evil and so I had a
great time had a great time
um in closing I won't keep you much
longer thank you so much for hanging out
where can people find you and what are
you up to right now
uh so right now I'm I just got back from
like a five-week trip on all these gigs
uh some conventions some streams uh
building project and BVI yeah I'm I'm
now kind of in chill mode yeah what I'm
doing now is I'm focusing on streaming a
little bit more catching up with friends
catching up on sleep yeah hobbies and
stuff like that writing some more music
so I'm just kind of just chilling right
now I'm like revitalizing the balance in
my life
uh you can find me on Instagram uh just
Nick underscore apos apos
um you'll find a lot of my updates there
uh streaming it's just my full name the
capacity lead us twitch.tv
um
yeah that's probably the best I have a
long last name it's Greek even my
friends can't pronounce it and they
can't spell it so yeah links would be
great um that's where to find me I'm
just you know I'm just a creative
floating around just trying to do some
fun stuff that's it thank you so much
pretty great job congratulations well
thank you thank you for having me though
I really appreciate it I'm glad that we
got to make this happen yeah and at some
point soon we said so on the stream but
uh a friend of us Susie the Sofia Hunter
we're going to do a charity stream play
resume before maybe we'll do a speed run
at some point so stay tuned for that yes
um but yeah I'll leave links in the
description where you can check out Nick
and thank you see you guys next time
[Music]
thank you foreign